how you doing
hi leia hi daniel so good to see both of
you uh i wore a tie just for you i have
no idea how to do it you look great
it looks okay right
moment of truth daniel uh you got to see
this film with everybody uh was this
film everything you wanted was this the
love letter the big hurrah you wanted
for bond
uh yes it kind of was um it's what it's
i mean listen it's a
huge
uh collaborative effort um
um you know not least of all from people
like leia and an amazing cast that we
have
and put in
people put their heart into this movie
and i think it shows on the screen uh we
saw it the other night in the royal
albert hall with a with a with a full
cinema
a full roll outfit hall effect um and um
we got the reactions we wanted we got
everything and so i'm just
i'm just very keen for people to see the
movie i think it's i think it's
beautiful film and there's lots of great
things in it
a good reason to go back to cinema
truly truly and let's talk about that
night you got the royal family came out
duchess kate was there leia what did she
say to you she was in that dress you
were in that dress what was that moment
like
yeah we spoke about uh our dresses
um
no it was uh it was um
you know it's such a i mean james bond
is a national treasure yeah so um
so um two two two two
to just to to premiere the film for the
first time
uh in london with the
royal family and
you know all the
i mean
to be like with with the every i mean
all the people and uh the
[Music]
and the health uh
um workers workers my workers yeah
was was also like uh
um
very meaningful you know and
it was the first time that uh we
we
yeah yeah that i that it was the first
time i saw the film with with an
audience and
that was uh
that was very i mean
emotional because the film as you know
has been postponed several times yeah
and it was now really the time
it felt like that people were enjoying
you know and uh happy to be
to be there
and and it's it's also uh
cinema is a
isn't it is an experience that uh
you know we have to share yeah emotions
and it was just uh
and daniel i found this photo
um
well done royale
was this the moment you felt like you
were born
do you remember this what's that
was this the moment you felt that you
were bond that this was officially the
moment
it might have been when other people
thought i was born but i already knew i
was born by that book
uh and finally i know um
this is your big horizon
you know we saw those moments with you
with your your cast with that movie of
being bond
i know a lot of people are asking but
would you deliver that famous line for
me
no i'm done
the job's not mine anymore
i'm done and dusted with that thank you
though i love that take care thank you
so much for this film congratulations to
the both of you
all right thank you take care